since the start of adulthood we have
been waiting
we understood love intuitively long
before it was ever a practical
possibility we knew that it was bound up
with a sense of being profoundly
understood and finally able to say
everything without fear of judgment or
censure love was a two-person conspiracy
against everyone else too dumb or leaden
to get it the true nature of being alive
it had to do with fancying someone
totally and the amazingness that they
might fancy you back to the extent that
you could do anything with them like
rest a finger inside their mouth and
asked them to bite it hard we imagined
from the first that love might be the
best part of life and we weren't wrong
in the name of love we put ourselves in
extraordinary situations we went out far
more than we would have wanted
we bought fancy clothes we thought about
our hair and worried about our spots
we drank intensely colored cocktails we
ended up at small hours in alien parts
of town in the bedrooms of people when
you weren't quite right but that seemed
at least in some way to be an advance on
the cause we accepted dates with people
when you were problematic because we
wanted not to ossify or grow alone and
peculiar it wasn't always right in fact
it was mostly always wrong but we kept
our spirits up and told ourselves it
would eventually be okay as they kindly
assured us it would be but time passed
decades went by we got in meshed in some
very troubling situations that look like
love from the outside but were anything
but we spent far too long extra gating
ourselves and finding our voice and at a
certain point we started to apprehend
something whose terror we're still
grappling with probably late at night
because such things aren't easy to look
at in daylight the probability that love
isn't after all despite our efforts and
insights ever gonna come right for us we
are going to die without ever having
known the love we so longed for the
reasons are multiple
in their ways entirely banal because our
past is too complicated our lack of
trust too deep we're too ugly
we're too unconfident we don't meet the
right people our luck is too slim hope
feels too risky though we try harder
than we tried anything else we can't do
this thing it won't work out for us the
ambassador for this Samba Quran truth
might be an objectively rather innocuous
disappointment perhaps one more date
that didn't in the end despite a very
hopeful stage around dessert go as it
should or one more person who didn't
call back they the angel of romantic
death couldn't have known what they were
doing to us and certainly didn't mean to
we can't hate them for a moment
unfortunately but through their lack of
desire they initiated us into an idea
which now threatens to blow our sanity
behind closed doors the scenes aren't
pretty
thank goodness for privacy to shield a
moralistic world from whales that need
to be forgotten there will be hours of
the most unofficial tears bitter
denunciations of everyone in everything
self pitying and vengeful rants this is
too much I can't take it anymore this is
unfair beyond measure in the night we
smashed through the crash barriers of
ordinary hope we're going to do away
with ourselves they'll regret us they'll
miss us now but we won't of course do
anything silly it's just the mind doing
its normal work adjusting to yet another
yawning gap between the way we would
want things to be and the horrid way
they are we settle we are after all
creatures who know how to die we think
we don't know how to but we invariably
do whatever the fierce rage we can
digest pretty much any verdict we tell
ourselves we'd never endure not being
able to speak or losing our bowels but
then the doctors tell us what has to be
and we put up with a feeding tube and a
bag and being able to communicate only
through a quivering eyelid it's always
better than the alternative so of course
we deal with a cataclysmic lack of love
dawn comes chilly and severe and yet
reassuring in its sober bleakness we
make the bed clear away the despair and
get on there are a few consolations
first and foremost a ravaged incensed
defiance a [ __ ] you to the universe and
all those who peddle sentimental
nonsense that doesn't fit our reality a
certain kind of art works too the sort
created by unflinching genius realists
who went through as much loneliness as
we have who understood our sadness ahead
of time grief-stricken masters like
Baudelaire and Leopardi pessoa and
Pascal who can express our petty
domestic sorrow in mighty transcendental
terms and induct us to the most
dignified kind of regret they were there
to and in the most abstract accomplished
ways tell us I know and we have
friendship not the kind that obliterates
the loneliness but that allows us to
community can't help each other directly
we're more like a group of the dying in
a hospice talking circle who won't be
able to eradicate the end but know they
are at least not alone with it we get
better too at understanding statistics
that this is normal for ABBA knighted
group of us we belong to an important
minority party in the Parliament of
human suffering lovelessness will have
been our major burden a grief that
endured from adolescents to the end a
problem that was meant to go away and
never did on our secret gravestone it
should say love didn't work out for them
and how they longed that it might an
epitaph to frighten children and
reassure our emotional successors what
was meant to be just a phase turned into
the truest thing about us that we longed
for love and that it never came a truth
all the more redemptive for being
expressed at last with a rare calm
unflinching honesty
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life
you